Шановні колеги А що ми обговорюємо Якщо
у нас воюючій країні Служба безпеки
України немає свого керівника і
президент України досі не вніс
кандидатуру на очільника цього ключового
відомства А що ми обговорюємо якщо
попереднього голову служби безпеки
України зняли за статтею вперше в
історії України недбальства яке призвело
до загибелі людей і ми вимагаємо аби
заслухали така про що йшлося що ж
натворилася Служба безпеки України що
призвело до загибелі людей ми вимагаємо
так само зустрітися з виконуючим
обов'язки керівництва служби безпеки
України в рамках погоджувальної чи
будь-якої ради для того щоб почути про
якісь міфічні бета-ферми які начебто там
вони накривали замість того щоб боротися
з колаборантами і зрадниками щодо цього
законопроекту у нас дійсно сьогодні
посилюють ним авторитарні тенденції
держави приму зустрічі від Ради
нацбезпеки і оборони в такому ручному
режимі формувати знаєте якісь там пакети
терористів Так у нас половина терористів
із радників сьогодні нагороджується
державними нагородами у нас Медаль за
заслуги в останньому указі президента
Зеленського стала Медаллю за обслугову
тому що туди включили людей які після
14-го року у Москві ротом співали на
концертах Победы або тих хто бігали по
луганському футболку зелёные человечки и
вежливые Люди знайте будь ласка те що
відбувається зараз в Верховній Раді
України коли ви
відмовляєтеся робити трансляцію засідань
це означає що тут відбувається нечесні
дії тому що коли немає що приховувати то
не треба і приховувати А цей
законопроект треба поховати тут в
зародиш